We have a very talented roster.
We have a very talented team.
But the reason we have
a chance to be great
is we're really good at grinding.
I always think the best CEOs are grinders.
Yes, you have to have a vision.
Yes, you gotta set a culture.
But the best ones, it's not
about them, it's the grinding.
Grinding, it's a concept that resonates
in the blue collar town of Philadelphia,
a city that loves its football team.
They'll even spell it out for you.
E-A-G-L-E-S, Eagles!
I think Philadelphians are just eager
for any type of joy that we can get.
Go Birds!
I will say that our level of booing,
chef's kiss, best in the world.
While Eagles fans are infamous,
the team's owner, Jeffrey Lurie,
may at first glance seem
like the polar opposite
to the Philly Faithful.
A PhD wielding Hollywood film producer
who grew up in Boston?
That's not what many
have deemed a Philly guy.
And in his time, he has made
some unpopular decisions.
The Philadelphia Eagles
select Jalen Hurts.
What?
What the ?
We're not risk averse and we
never wanna be risk averse,
whether it's on the football field or off.
And that allows you to have this culture
that can achieve some
successes continuously.
He's not your typical owner,
and so he's not going to think or operate
like all the other owners.
In his nearly 30 years with the team,
he's gone from being the
youngest owner in the league
to a standard bearer of
what modern NFL ownership
looks like.
We're stewards of something
incredibly popular.
Let's run it well but at the same time,
let's really make a big difference
in the communities and across the country
and maximize our love for each other.
Just off Broad Street
in South Philadelphia
sits the Eagles NovaCare Complex.
I'm here today to meet with
their owner, Jeffrey Lurie.
Now, if you're outside of Philadelphia,
you might not know his name
and that's not an
accident or an oversight.
Lurie hasn't been one to sit down
for long interviews in the past,
but I wanted to understand
how he views himself,
his businesses, and the future of running
a pro football team.
You know, as I was thinking about you
and preparing for this, it struck me,
this is not a franchise
that has these massive highs
and then, like, stunning lows, as it were.
There's a consistency to it.
How do you create both a
culture and an organization
that is able to sustain?
So not easy, and I think what
we were able to do early on
is establish that culture.
That culture is very intense, hardworking,
blue collar culture within an organization
that's very focused on the
key things that drive success.
Jeffrey Lurie has owned
the Eagles since 1994.
It's an investment that you'd have to say
has paid off for him.
He bought the team for just
under 200 million dollars
and estimates today put the
team at 4.9 billion dollars.
One of the things that I've found
to be true in pro football,
probably to a greater degree
than the average fan realizes,
is that ownership really
has an effect on the team.
If you have a good owner then
you have a real chance to win.
If you have a bad owner,
it just poisons the whole organization.
NFL ownership styles
vary around the league
to say the least,
maybe best illustrated
by the owners within the
Eagle's own division.
The New York Football
Giants have been owned
by the Mara family and their
offspring for nearly 100 years.
It's a family business passed
down through generations.
Down in DC, the newly
renamed Washington Commanders
are, for the moment, owned by Dan Snyder.
Snyder is, to say the least, unpopular.
Sell the team! Sell the team!
And his tenure has been plagued
by accusations of personal
and financial misconduct
leading to federal investigations
and calls even from fellow owners
to sell the team, which he may finally do.
Then in Dallas, you have Jerry Jones.
I hope there's some Cowboy fans here.
Maybe the most recognizable
sports owner on the planet,
he has successfully marketed the Cowboys
into being the most valuable
sporting franchise ever.
The team was valued by Sportico
at a staggering 7.6
billion dollars in 2022.
There're all sorts of different owners.
I mean, some owners like the visibility,
some owners get into this
because they love the visibility.
After games, he stands in
the middle of the locker room
and people go to him before they go
to the coaches and players in
some cases, and he loves that.
And Jeffrey is on the other side of that.
If I'm tuning in to
sports radio, you know,
you're not doing a WIP call in show.
I mean, this in and of
itself is pretty rare for you
to sit down and have an
extended conversation.
Is that your personality?
Is it a business choice?
Like, why sort of take that approach?
So, you know, for me,
it's not wanting to...
It's much more wanting to
embrace the fans directly,
not through gatekeepers.
So I always saw sports talk
radio as interesting, valuable
to, you know, for fans but
it's a very different business.
We're in the business
of trying to win big,
have a great organization,
represent the the
community in a great way.
We're not into wanting to monetize drama.
That's in stark contrast to Jerry Jones,
whose strategy has meant repeatedly
placing and finding himself at the center
of every conversation and
controversy tied to his team,
whether he means to or not.
Financially, it's worked out
despite the team only
winning three playoff games
in the last 25 years.
Lurie's far more reserved approach
puts him in a more familiar
setting, behind the camera.
And local residents,
they're more than happy
for the spotlight.
I think the fans are the star of the show.
My name is Ahmir Questlove Thompson.
I am a musician, member
of The Roots, a director,
and a proud Philadelphian.
Quick time out here, Questlove?
We're gonna get more into this later.
But beyond being a Philadelphia native,
six time Grammy award-winning musician,
author, and podcaster,
he's also a film director.
He won his first Oscar
for his first movie,
a film called "Summer of Soul"
which Jeffrey Lurie executive produced
in his other business,
documentary filmmaking.
But for now, let's get
back to those Eagles fans.
Even though it's a cosmopolitan city,
it's really a blue collar town.
It's a wolf in sheep's clothing.
It's a blue collar town in the
drape of a cosmopolitan city.
We're elegant, but we also
might have a pack of batteries
inside the inside pockets.
Winning a Super Bowl
meant the world to me.
And the first thing I did
after we won the Super Bowl
was get this Eagles lip tattoo.
Whether it's lip tattoos
with the score of Super
Bowl LII, getting arrested.
Go Eagles.
Or whatever this is.
It's a passionate fan base
that is gonna let you know how they feel,
even while rescuing children from fires.
Oh my man, just start throwing
babies out the window,
we was catching them, unlike Agholor.
Local news stars aside,
with such a vocal fan base,
Lurie has often gone
against popular wisdom.
With the second pick,
the Philadelphia Eagles
select Donovan McNabb,
quarterback, Syracuse University.
And while some decisions,
like taking quarterback Donovan McNabb
over running back Ricky
Williams, worked out,
others not so much.
The Philadelphia Eagles
select Jalen Reagor.
I've never wanted to
make popular decisions.
I kind of grew up in Boston
with a baseball team at the time
that always kind of made popular decisions
and they always kind of
ended up not doing very well.
And I always thought, you know,
if I ever had the chance
to run or own a team,
don't ever try to make popular decisions.
Try to make what you think is best.
If we're gonna have to change a coach,
it's gonna be change for a great reason,
for a coach that can provide
something that's been missing.
If it's a player mistake, don't continue
to make that investment in that
player mistake, but move on.
Have sort of a self-critical nature,
that's part of the culture.
I think that's been one
of our keys to success
is we pay very little
attention to the outside noise
and recognize some of it is
true, some of it's not true.
And the best thing you can do
is do what you think is right.
And recently for NFL owners,
doing the right thing goes
beyond the football field.
NFL team facilities tend to be shrines
to the players and personalities
of the team's past.
But right as you enter,
you'll notice something a little different
about the NovaCare complex.
A wall of heroes honoring
Martin Luther King Jr.,
Nelson Mandela, and Dr. Paul Farmer.
This is not the typical
entrance to a football facility.
Very early on after owning the team,
I thought, you know, the
values we really wanna present
to our players, our employees,
everybody involved in it
is football is incredible,
it's the most popular sport in America,
but let the values be even bigger.
We're out there, we're out
there to have a great practice.
You know, we're singularly
focused on the next play,
the next practice, the next game.
And yet our lives, we're human beings,
and this is a chance to kind
of put it all in perspective.
And it doesn't take away
from being hyper-competitive.
It makes you wanna make a difference
whether it's on the football field or off.
I think it ups your odds on winning.
While over Lurie's tenure,
the Eagles have taken
up a number of causes
all around the Philadelphia area.
More recently, Lurie's focused
his philanthropic efforts
closer to home on autism research.
Thank you all for being here today
and for your unwavering commitment
to helping improve the lives
of those impacted by autism.
You know, I hesitated for a long time
integrating my wanting
to try to make an impact
in the world of autism
'cause of my brother
and the family business, so to speak.
It became something where I wasn't needing
to, like, push it aside,
but saying, you know what?
We could be a sports team
that absolutely identifies
with a underfunded condition
that affects millions around the world
and kind of make it so that
there's no real difference
between the Eagles and autism.
As you notice, at the
end of every end zone,
we have Eagles Autism Foundation.
So every time there's a TV
shot of a score, a field goal,
whatever's going on, the Eagles
and autism are synonymous.
That was my goal because that allows us
to reach millions of people.
It allows us to have terrific fundraising.
It's amazing to see our
players and everybody
wanna be part of it.
Philanthropy across the
entire NFL is also changing,
spurred by a workforce, the players,
who have louder voices
and higher expectations.
Today's NFL occupies a
unique and important place
in American culture, reflecting
often, in stark terms,
the biggest opportunities and challenges.
Great wealth and individual success,
right alongside a history that includes
systematic racism, sexism,
and abuse of power.
The past several years have
seen NFL players fight for
voting rights, equality, and more
by leveraging their fame and influence.
Do you feel the expectations
have been raised for ownership
during your tenure as an owner?
I do, I do, in a good way.
I think we're really
challenged to be good,
really good community examples.
And let's not just be,
we're the NFL, we're so
successful, we dominate television,
our valuations are gigantic.
Let's absolutely be the
best citizens we can be
and let's judge ourselves
not just on the field
but off the field.
Lurie's also leaned into
the interest of his players
when it comes to social issues,
most notably in the recent
past with Malcolm Jenkins.
Are you not gonna say anything today
or just gonna use these posters?
I cherish having, you
know, players like Malcolm.
I encourage players to be
really community involved.
I always really enjoyed his ability
to think through what
he wanted to accomplish
and then set a series of short
term mechanisms to do it.
We are here to use our
leverage, our voices
to make sure that our families,
our communities, our kids
are a priority.
Continuing this legacy of using the NFL
as a platform for change,
quarterback Jalen Hurts
has been raising awareness
around gun violence,
all with the support and
amplification of the Eagles.
I think the more important
thing is the platform we have
and the opportunity we have to
impact the people around us.
There's definitely an
intersection between sports,
entertainment, and popular culture.
It's up to us, the leaders
in those industries,
to be able to celebrate
the beauty that we have
and attack the problems that we have.
'Cause there's real problems
of poverty, inequality,
social injustice, these are real.
Yet at the same time,
let's celebrate the wonderful
people that we have.
Lurie's own off-field
platform, making movies,
allows him another avenue
to advance important conversations.
His films document seminal
but often little known
moments in American history,
stories that give voice
to our collective complicated relationship
with race and equality.
And the winner is "Summer of Soul,
When the Revolution
Could Not Be Televised."
Ahmir Thompson
and four white guys.
So here's a funny thing.
So the normal protocol,
especially with documentaries,
is you usually just have,
like, one benefactor,
like one producer, one
person to finance it.
This film was very
unusual in the fact that
everyone sort of wanted in on the action.
And when I saw the name Jeff Lurie,
I was like, "Nah, it's not him, anyway."
And went on and I saw the name again
and I was like,
"Wait, isn't this the guy
that owns the Eagles?"
And they're like, "Yeah."
I was like, "Wait, he's
in the movie business?
Who knew?"
Like I had zero clue.
The movie industry was the family business
for Jeffrey Lurie.
His grandfather Phillip
Smith was an entrepreneur
in the movie theater business.
He helped popularize the drive-in
and the suburban shopping mall theater.
It's interesting when you
parallel and look at, you know,
what I'm doing now,
but it was all focused on making
the enjoyment of watching,
like the fan of movies,
enjoy their experience.
So big beautiful screens,
clean bathrooms, easy parking.
This was his way in
to try to get people to
appreciate storytelling.
Lurie has produced
some narrative films over the years
but of late, documentary has been
the effort of his company
Play/Action Pictures.
Lurie received his third
Oscar for "Summer of Soul."
It got presented to us
as, "This is a project.
would you like to help
from the very beginning
with Questlove?
And we've got access to the
archives of all this music,"
and we just thought it was
a perfect project for us.
And often we will take
stories that happen,
history that happened
that has a very, very real
present day relevance.
Like I've seen rubber
stamping in the industry,
especially with the executive producers.
You know, talk to my
people, they'll explain
and I'll do the final
signature, yep, it's good to go.
Jeff is really, really
passionate about movies
and, you know, he had notes
for every rough draft that we sent.
You know, we did at least
five cuts of "Summer of Soul."
His notes were front and center
Welcome to the Harlem Cultural Festival.
Built around never scene footage
of the 1969 Harlem Cultural Festival,
"Summer of Soul" ultimately tells a story
not just of an amazing lineup of artists,
but of what their hidden history
says about America then and now.
It started out just as a
cool mixtape of performances
and then it wound up
really being a life lesson.
It was one where I love
showing it to our players.
They were, in most cases,
like, shocked at the late
sixties and what was going on
both in the country
and the humanity of it.
So a lot of the parallels
here of owning a team,
having a documentary film company
is to explore the humanity
and elevate the value of human beings
that really need to be elevated
as an example in society for all of us.
And it strikes me that that
outlook, philosophy, ethos,
however you want to describe it, you know,
it comes into sharp relief
in the summer of 2020.
Protests over the death of George Floyd
while in police custody
now in their eighth night.
The remarkable scenes
that have been unfolding
in cities across this country yet again.
There's a lot of your work that starts
to come to a very fine
point at that moment.
Your worlds are colliding to some extent,
in terms of what you've
done as a filmmaker
and what you're doing as
the owner of this franchise.
Take me back to that summer.
So obviously very difficult
summer, but not atypical.
There's a lot of taking
down of Black citizens
all across the country
every day, every week.
But, you know, a terribly
polarized time in America
and a lot of anger coming out.
Suddenly the very issues
that we were dealing with in 1969,
we were also dealing with
those same exact issues
50 years later.
I will say that this
entire decade from 2020 on,
will be sort of a new establishment
and a new beginning for the platform
and who gets to speak on that platform.
While Lurie continues to work with
players and filmmakers in
areas of representation,
on the football field,
the Eagles have also
played a key role in
elevating Black players
to the most coveted role in the game,
the quarterback position.
Entering the 2022 season,
the Eagles had the most games
started by a black quarterback
in the history of the NFL with 360.
In comparison, their rival,
the New York Giants had only one ever.
You know, first of all,
we're trying to get the
best possible quarterback
so it's not in any way,
"Well, oh, okay, this person
is black," or whatever,
that's never been the case.
We always want to get the best player.
On the other hand,
whatever I'm involved in,
I think there's a feeling
of sort of undervalued,
certainly felt that with Donovan McNabb.
Nobody had ever drafted a
black quarterback that high
in the history of the NFL
at the time, number two.
We were lucky to get him, I mean,
we were so lucky that the
team who had the first pick
undervalued him.
His mobility and his ability
to be dynamic on the field
were probably undervalued by
that team and goes on and on.
With Michael Vick, it was more,
this man deserves a second chance.
The things he got involved
in were awful, you know?
I describe him as heinous
with dogs and I'm a dog lover.
But we felt in America at
that time and still to today,
often black people don't
get second chances.
And this was a man who was very talented.
That's why he was getting a second chance.
But also because we believed his desire
to make good on some of the, you know,
things that he caused a
lot of pain were real.
And Michael proved us to be right
for giving him the second chance.
So there's a history
to Randall, to Donovan.
We had Rodney Pete, I could
add Jalen Hurts to that.
Just all excellent
people, comes down to it.
Excellent people who
probably were undervalued.
And so whether it's Black
musicians in the sixties
or quarterbacks in the, you know,
nineties and two thousands,
there's a similarity.
So I feel like we've been
like leading up to a moment
where I ask you sort of one of
these big sweeping questions.
What's your advice, as the
future of the NFL unfolds,
for someone who is coming into this now?
Well first of all, come into
it if you love the sport,
don't come into it like you're
just running a business.
It's not the same.
Number two, manage your team
to the best of your ability
and not what outside world influences.
Those are short term influences.
Don't pay attention to that stuff.
Don't try to be popular.
That'll create unpopularity,
basically, in the long run.
Lurie's giving that kind of advice
in real time to his son Julian,
who has worked for the NFL
and recently joined the Eagles full-time
in a business and football
operation strategy role.
Lurie Senior, having grown up
in another family business,
has turned the Eagles into his own
and plans to pass it down,
with an expectation that his children
will run it with the same attention.
But it feels like 30, 40 years ago,
you could sort of be a
gentleman owner, right?
You could just sort of, like, rock up
to the stadium on Sundays.
I'm sure you could.
But today? No way.
No, and you won't be successful.
You gotta be really passionate
and you feel that weekly
ultra-competitive nature.
And it's also what makes it great.
I love that competitive juices.
You're not manufacturing widgets,
you are trying to maximize human beings.
Even better than the movies?
Even better than the movies.
Even much better than the movies, yeah.